hello everyone and welcome back to the
coverage of the Magnus Invitational we
are continuing with the match a young
opponent she vs. ali reza fuchsia but as
tomorrow we had four pairs of people
playing chess I will not be able to
cover all of the games so here I'm just
going to cover the Armageddon game I was
it was a really tough match between the
two of them you know just back and forth
back and forth
a lot of the size of games but now we
reach Armageddon where Young has the
white pieces he has five minutes against
Allah dresses for and he needs to win to
win the match
and it is quite a game but before we
check it out I do have two announcements
one is as it's Friday we're going to
have two tournaments again today the
meadow arena the warm-up for the main
event target matters Friday arena so the
links to both of the tournaments will be
in the description below so do join and
I will also put a link to our team on
leashes so you can join our team as well
for future tournaments but also there's
a there's an option on leat just now
where I can message all of the members
at once so bye I just created tournament
and then I send you the link to the
tournament so you don't have to worry
about where's the link where is the
tournament and so on so if you want to
join our team as well
another thing it's the first of the
month so every first of the month or
maybe every third first of the month I
will I will
well I will suggest that you check that
YouTube did not unsubscribe you from the
channel against your will as YouTube
sometimes will do that thinking maybe
maybe you're a bot or if you don't
comment or if you don't engage with with
the community they might think you were
bought and then they will delete your
subscription so make sure that didn't
happen to you so that's one well that's
basically two announcements in the third
announcement I will now announce my
first guest for the Argan matter podcast
that is starting this month and well
some of you did have it right the first
guest for the Argan Matra podcast is
none other than I'm sure you know who it
is is Maxime Bashir allograph so there
we have it
hopefully it's gonna be a good podcast
I've never done a podcast but I'm very
excited about it and I hope I will do a
good job so I'm also offering you this
opportunity
there is also an email in
description below it says agamotto
podcast at gmail.com so you're more than
welcome to send some of your own
questions that you would like to ask
Maxine so you know if you ever thought
about you know what would you ask Maxine
if you you know saw him walking down the
street then just send that question to
have a matter podcast at gmail.com and I
will I will also include that question
among the other questions during the
podcast so that being said let's check
out the game so this is Armageddon
nipple with the white pieces he needs a
win and he goes for efore Alireza sticks
with his caro-kann defense we have C 6 d
4 D 5 and E 5 nipple goes for the
advanced variation of the caro-kann and
Bishop to f5 not not worrying about any
g4 ideas which it doesn't seem to be all
that popular in the top level so Knight
to f3 and e 6 now closing the cage here
now the bishop is free Bishop to e2 and
Knight to e7 we have C 3 by nipple
strengthening the center and h6 now if
the bishop is under attack you can just
tuck your Bishop oh wait - h7 we have
castles and now Knight to d7 and all the
rest has a very solid setup here he
managed to develop his light square
bishop and the center is nicely closed
that the Knights are very very solid
here and he will just continue
developing maybe some b6 rook to c8
maybe c5 in the future and so on so
Knight bTW - by Napo and a5 now grabbing
more space in the center preparing a 4
we have rook to e1 developing and also
preparing the F 1 square for the knight
so you can shift it over to g3 to go
after the bishop on f5 we have a 4 and
now Knight to F 1 re maneuvering the
knight will push up the g6 not waiting
for the bishop to be under attack and
still Knights to g3 and there is one
game in the database where Knights to
see it was played but here we have C 5
by Fallujah and it is a new move in the
position so already as a move 11 we have
a completely new game we have Bishop to
b5 now by nip oh and now comes a three
as there is now a double attack on the
pawn here all there is adjust the push
is a three he doesn't mind giving up
upon the mess-up neighboors pawn
structure and
of course not interested he goes b3 and
now the rook is stuck regarding the a3
pawn here we have Knight to c6 and here
Quinta e to just continuing development
C captors on d4 and now Knight captures
on d4 we have Queen to b6 AB developing
the Queen putting pressure on the d4
Knight and the Bishop to e3 now
threatening a lot of nasty discoveries
so Bishop to c5 not allowing this end
here nipple goes for Bishop captures and
c6 b captures and now getting rid of
this nasty bishop here with b4 we have
blush of character son before Bishop
captures on d4 and now Queen to b5
offering the Queen trade and neppo
declines Queen the g4 we have h5
attacking the Queen and now point h4
making it a bit problematic for fuchsia
for example if you want to go for
something like Knight b6 to c4 then
Bishop to c5 will be a real problem so
you will have to do something weird like
like King to d7 start running or Knight
to c8 or something like that
so instead immediately c5 by fallujah
going after that Bishop B captors and we
have Knight captures now and Knight to
e2 a preparing night to afford to go
after the bishop here but fallujah
doesn't allow it we have Knights to d3
attacking the rook and also covering the
f4 square looked at f1 defending in the
f2 phone once again and now Queen for c4
not allowing the bishop to move as the
Queen will be under attack and also if
the knight moves not not a very not a
very pleasant position for white so here
a knight the g3 first you cannot go to a
for like we've said and now the question
is what do you do here with fear is just
pieces do you capture the pawn as it
seems like it's a free pawn but it's
it's quite unclear for example if
captures you cannot recapture because
you lose the Queen but you can go f4
push back the night and after 96 you can
capture on g7 so it's a it's a position
to consider however it's a it's not a
it's not a terrible position here
Jerusha went for rook to b8 instead he
wants to do a nice rook lift with rook
to be to maybe add another attacker to
DF do pawn
but now neppo finds f4
now he defends d5 point and you no
longer have this this Knight captures on
e5 idea so tonight the c5 by Fallujah
and well 95 of course nipple wants to
play f5 and it's hard to it's hard to
find a way how to counter f5 so here
Napo decides tonight the c5 he's gonna
capture here and shift the night over to
e6 okay
Napo continues with f5 and now he
captures on f5 we have Knight captures
on f5 and and out Bishop captures rook
captures and fallujah now shifts the
night over to e 6 putting pressure on
the bishop here and now rook the rook a
to F 1 by nipple putting pressure on the
f7 pawn and now the problem is you can't
castle here to defend it like this
because then just rope captures and it's
game over there is no there's no
escaping this what you could try is g5
but g5 is a crazy move and it's hard to
it's impossible to calculate everything
that happens after g5 for example rook
captures and g5 Knight captures and
Queen captures and now rook to f8 adding
another defender but now e 6 and of
course the engine prefers Y T incredibly
here and you would do but it's hard to
decide on such a move when when the time
on the clock is very low so instead
fallujah goes for rook to b7 adds
another defender to the f7 pawn this way
but here at nipple just captures the
pawn rook captures on h5 and ok it's not
a problem later on you will be able to
capture on d4 twice maybe and now rook
captures on h5 we have Queen captures on
h5 and now Knight captures on d4 so it
seems like Fallujah solved all of his
problems however that there is one way
nipple can keep the action going so feel
free to pause the video and try to find
it the best move for an echo here while
I give you a couple of seconds so for
those of you who were able to do it
congratulations on spotting the correct
and maneuvers with the Queen to align
with the knight on d4 and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show it's
Queen h8 check now the problem is if you
go to d7 you're getting made rook
captures on f7 checking c6 and now Queen
here check juster wins the game that
there's nothing you can do check check
check check in here
check mate so you have to go to East
seven which is what phir aaja played but
now Queen back to h4 check and now you
defended the d4 square so King to e8 but
now see characters on d4 and this saves
the d4 pawn and the chances for nepo to
actually win this game as he's now up
upon but okay it's only one pawn future
goes for it
rook the b4 attacks the d4 pawn but now
Queen h8 check now never wants the trade
he has central pawns for this point so
King's the e7 and Queen captures and g7
which will also defend the e5 pawn queen
characters on d4 with check King - h1 in
the now comes Queen 2f do we reach the
position from the thumbnail Jerusha
offers a queen for a nice checkmate on
b1 so nipple has to do something about
it he goes Queen to g5 check and here
amazingly critical position and future
goes kinked East 6 Quinta d7 is is just
a normal move that doesn't allow white
any chances but King to e6 however
completely blunders the game for
Fallujah so once again feel free to
pause the video and try to find the
winning idea for an epic while I give
you a couple of seconds so for those of
you who were able to do it
congratulations unsporting why the king
was better on b7 than an e6 and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show
Queen 2 c1 now the point is you
reintroduce the threat of rook captures
an f2 since there will be no maid here
so black has to react by moving the
Queen and there is no good way to move
the Queen as the white queen is planning
Queen to c6 check so for example if you
go Queen to b6 just rook f6 check wins
the Queen so that's not going to work
out so here if you just ride Queen to e2
but this still doesn't work as an
empanada just goes for a queen to see
sex with check and you don't have a move
here you you have two options one is to
go to East 7 but then it's a queen to c7
check and then after you go back it's
just well you either go here and it's
made or you go to e8 and then just Queen
captures on f7 and you're going to get
made it very soon
so the other option is to cap captured
upon which is what fallujah did but now
never just play Quinta eh check and it
was in this position that all there is a
future
design the game as after the King moves
wherever you just pick up the Queen and
it's game over
so I'm really really exciting exciting
match every game was really exciting but
especially the Armageddon which was just
which was just incredibly crazy Fallujah
had a lot of chances he had a very solid
position a very very much playable
position but in the end and Nepal
prevailed s and nip was a very tricky
player sure like I said do check out the
tournaments the links to the tournaments
will be in the description below also
the link to join our elite chess team
will be in the description below and
also the mail agamotto broadcast at
gmail.com where you can send your
questions that you would wish to ask
Maxie Marshall a grab for me to include
in the podcast that I will be releasing
this month so yeah that's the game I do
hope you enjoyed it I would like to
thank Andrea Chi Chi now Pollock [ __ ]
even lamont a South Abdullah and superb
energy for your contribution to my
channel thank you a lot I really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and I will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the Magnus
Invitational until it finishes and yes
of course I forgot here are the
standings of the of the tournament after
the preliminary rounds oh sorry about
that some special effects are needed
here here's a nice cross table from just
24 website there you have it so the last
four places have been decided
it's young upon initial it has a few
genève giri and maxine washer a graph
and of course the other four are still
battling it out in the knockout stage of
the tournament for the top four top four
spots so Nakamura cross and ink and
Caruana so once again I do hope you
enjoyed it
think of for watching and I will see you
soon